You probably missed this. It wasn't big news this week. Congressman Charles Schumer of New York held a press conference on Monday with the head of the New York City police. Two auxiliary policemen had been shot and killed in the line of duty a year ago while confronting a gunman named David Garvin. Federal law says that the families of public safety officers, even volunteers like these auxiliary police, should get death benefits when something like that happens.
你可能错过了这条消息。这并不是本周的头条新闻。纽约州国会议员查尔斯·舒默周一与纽约市警察局长举行了新闻发布会。一年前，两名辅助警察在执勤时面对一名叫大卫·加文的持枪歹徒，不幸殉职。联邦法律规定，公共安全人员的家属，即使是像这些辅助警察这样的志愿者，在发生此类事件时也应获得死亡抚恤金。
But the Justice Department turned them down on a technicality, and on Monday Schumer was mad.
但司法部以技术性问题拒绝了他们的申请，舒默在周一对此感到非常愤怒。
The officers, they were in uniform, they had shields. They had gone through four months of the NYPD's basic training course. They acted to protect their fellow New Yorkers that night as trained, experienced, NYPD volunteers. What more could the Justice Department be asking for? Yet they disagree. They don't qualify as officers of the peace through a faulty, narrow interpretation of the law that says because they didn't have the authority to arrest Mr. Garvin, they don't qualify.
这些警察身着制服，佩戴徽章。他们完成了纽约警察局为期四个月的基础训练课程。那天晚上，他们作为训练有素、经验丰富的纽约警察局志愿者，挺身而出保护了市民。司法部还能要求什么呢？但他们却不认同。他们通过对法律一种错误且狭隘的解读，认为这些人因无权逮捕加文先生，所以不符合治安官的资格，从而剥夺了他们的福利。
Auxiliary officers have the power to detain a suspect, but not to arrest him.
辅助警察有权拘留嫌疑人，但没有逮捕权。
It's as if the bureaucrats in Washington were looking for a way to get out of this responsibility. And what we have to do is persuade the Justice Department to stop playing these tawdry and really low games.
这简直就像华盛顿的官僚们在找借口推卸责任。我们必须促使司法部停止这种卑劣且下作的勾当。
Just a couple months ago, the family of volunteer fireman Glenn Winuk finally got the Justice Department to pay his death benefit. He died on September 11, at the World Trade Center, doing rescue work at  the south tower. Again, the department had fought the benefit on a technicality, and only paid after five years of fighting, when the federal courts ordered them to.
就在几个月前，志愿消防员格伦·温克的家属终于促使司法部支付了他的死亡抚恤金。他在9月11日世贸中心南塔执行救援任务时牺牲。同样，司法部也曾以技术性理由拒绝赔偿，在长达五年的抗争后，迫于联邦法院的裁决，他们才最终支付了抚恤金。
There is a style to this administration, what Yale Law professor Jack Balkin calls a "lawyering" style, where they fight as hard as they can every battle on all fronts, unrelentingly to get their way.
本届政府有一种独特的行事风格，耶鲁大学法学教授杰克·巴尔金称之为“律师式”风格，即他们会在所有战线上全力以赴地进行抗争，不达目的誓不罢休。
It's been an emphasis on taking extremely hard line positions on executive power and pushing them, really, as far as you can. Sometimes taking positions that would be seen to be unreasonable in the hopes that, in fact, either you'll get your way, because people will give in, or else, if they push back, they'll push back to a place where you actually get a lot of what you wanted in the first place.
他们极其强调在行政权力上采取强硬立场，并将其推向极致。有时甚至采取一些被视为不合理的立场，其希望在于：要么你会因为对方的让步而如愿以偿，要么即使对方反击，反击的结果也会让你实现大部分预期的目标。
For example, he says, take the way the administration has tried to get around the ban on torture. This is an area where the law had been thought to be completely clear. There are lots of statutes, there are treaties, that all made torture illegal in the United States. But the administration had several strategies to get around these.
他举例说，看看本届政府绕开禁止酷刑禁令的方式。在这个领域，法律曾被认为是极其明确的。有很多法规和条约都规定在美国禁止使用酷刑。但政府却有几种策略来绕开这些禁令。
One strategy was simply to define the word torture, or cruel, inhuman, degrading treatment, in such a narrow way that they didn't capture a lot of what ordinary citizens would think of as being torture. So what it is is just very narrow construction, unreasonable construction.
其中一种策略仅仅是将“酷刑”或“残忍、非人道、有辱人格的待遇”这些词的定义限定在极其狭窄的范围内，以至于无法涵盖普通公民所认为的酷刑。所以说，这完全是极其狭隘且不合理的解读。
But the most interesting argument, the most innovative argument, the Bush administration made was this.
但布什政府提出的最有趣、最具创新性的论点是这样的。
That if push came to shove, and somebody were to claim that the president was in violation of the anti-torture statute, and the War Crimes Act, and all these other things, well these laws are simply unconstitutional as applied to the president when the president acts as commander-in-chief. Now that claim, the last claim, which was the president can't be bound by Congress when he acts in his capacity as commander-in-chief was, in fact, the most radical of all of the claims. It was close to the idea of the president as dictator. Since the president, when he acts in his capacity as commander-in-chief, can basically rule by decree. And he can't be bound by laws to the contrary.
如果事态升级，有人声称总统违反了反酷刑法规、《战争罪法》以及其他所有相关法律，那么这些法律在总统作为三军统帅行事时，对总统而言就是违宪的。而最后这一项主张，即总统在担任三军统帅时不受国会约束，实际上是所有主张中最激进的。这几乎等同于将总统视为独裁者。因为总统在以三军统帅身份行事时，基本上可以依靠政令进行统治，而不受任何反对法律的约束。
There are really two things about this that are new. First is the sheer inventiveness with which the president's men go about asserting the president's powers. They're using tactics and arguments that other presidents have not used, or used rarely. Second, and more important, the president is claiming that he has all kinds of powers the previous presidents have not claimed.
关于这一点，确实有两点是前所未有的。首先是总统幕僚们在行使总统权力时所表现出的那种纯粹的创造性。他们使用的战术和论点是其他总统未曾使用或极少使用的。第二点，也是更重要的一点，总统声称他拥有以往总统从未声称拥有的各种权力。
The president's men say that everything the executive branch does-- and, picture, that is a lot of things. These are the federal agencies that oversee the environment, and immigration, and education and energy policy. And especially when it comes to the job of commander-in-chief of the armed forces, they say nobody, no law, even a law passed by Congress and signed by the president himself, no law can tell the president what to do or how to do it. They say it's unconstitutional.
总统的幕僚们称，行政部门所做的一切——想象一下，这涵盖了极其广泛的领域。这些机构包括监管环境、移民、教育和能源政策的联邦机构。尤其是当涉及到三军统帅这一职能时，他们声称任何人、任何法律，即便是由国会通过并由总统本人签署的法律，都不能告诉总统该做什么或怎么做。他们声称这违宪。
This is such a radically new idea that even some conservatives have trouble with it. When the president was ignoring a law called the FISA law-- the FISA law says that if the president wants to spy on Americans' phone calls and emails, he can do that, but first he has to get permission from a special secret court to do it. When the president declared that he could just ignore that law, that law that is specifically targeted at his behavior, George Will said that this was a monarchical doctrine that was quote "refuted by the plain text of the Constitution." Grover Norquist said quote "There is no excuse for violating the law." Paul Weyrich wondered, what if a president he didn't like decided he could ignore any law. He worried, what would a president Hillary do with these same powers?
这是一个如此激进的新观点，以至于连一些保守派都难以接受。当总统无视《外国情报监视法》（FISA）——该法规定如果总统想要监听美国人的电话和电子邮件，他可以这样做，但首先必须获得一个秘密法庭的许可。当总统宣布他可以无视那部专门针对他行为的法律时，乔治·威尔表示这是一种“被宪法原文所驳斥”的君主制教条。格罗弗·诺奎斯特则称“违反法律没有任何借口”。保罗·韦里奇则担心，如果一个他不喜欢的总统决定可以无视任何法律怎么办。他担心，如果是希拉里担任总统，她会如何利用这些同样的权力？
Today we're going to talk about this lawyering style, this unrelenting style that the administration has. It's a style that kind of makes sense, when you're dealing with issues of national security and keeping the country safe-- with big stuff. But this style has become a habit. It seems to be applied to almost anything, even death benefits for firemen and police.
今天我们要讨论这种律师式的风格，这种政府所具有的执着风格。这种风格在处理国家安全和维护国家稳定这些大问题时，似乎还说得过去。但这种风格已经变成了一种习惯，甚至被应用到几乎所有的事情上，甚至是消防员和警察的死亡抚恤金问题上。
Well from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass. Our show today, The Audacity of Government. We're going to talk about this style the administration has. This unrelenting style. We have two stories for you. Not about big things, not about big government policies. These are tiny examples. Two of the thousands of little things that the federal government does that most of us never, ever hear about. Things so small that it is hard to understand why the administration is putting up such a fight about them in the first place. We look for answers. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由公共广播国际（PRI）发行，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是《政府的胆量》。我们将讨论本届政府的这种风格，这种执着的风格。我们有两个故事要讲。不是关于什么大事，不是关于大的政府政策。这些都是微小的例子。这是联邦政府所做的成千上万件小事中的两件，大多数人从未听说过。这些事情小到让人难以理解为什么政府从一开始就对此如此大动干戈。我们寻找答案。请继续收听。
Act one, The Commish versus the Prez. OK, let's stop and think for a second, and try to imagine the least controversial thing our government does when it comes to foreign policy. And I'm sure that there's some job out there stamping custom forms at the airports, or something like that, that is very, very, very, very uncontroversial. But, certainly, right up alongside that vital but boring task is the task of keeping crap off the border with Canada.
第一幕，局长对决总统。好吧，让我们停下来想一想，试着想象一下政府在外交政策方面所做的最不具争议的事情。我相信在机场盖印章之类的工作肯定是非常、非常、非常不具争议的。但是，肯定有一个任务与那项重要但枯燥的工作并列，那就是保持与加拿大边境的整洁。
That's right. For 10 feet on either side of our Canadian border, in what is called the 20 foot swath, or the border vista, nobody is supposed to build any buildings, or plant any trees, or erect any fences or do anything that would block the view. It's impossible to patrol the border if we can't actually see it and monitor it with security cameras and move freely along it. And so 10 feet on either side of the border is always kept clear, for the security of both countries.
没错。在美加边境两侧各10英尺的范围内，即所谓的“20英尺地带”或“边境景观区”，任何人都不允许建造任何建筑物、种植树木、竖立围栏或做任何阻挡视线的事情。如果我们无法实际看到它，无法用安全摄像头监控并沿其自由移动，那么巡逻边境是不可能的。因此，为了两国的安全，边境两侧各10英尺一直保持畅通。
Since the year 1908, this important job has been done by a special international commission run by two guys-- one from Canada, one from the US. They make the official map of the border, they put up little markers indicating where the border is. And occasionally, just a couple times a year, they have to tell somebody not to build 10 feet from the border.
自1908年以来，这项重要的工作一直由一个由两个人——一个加拿大人，一个美国人——运营的特别国际委员会负责。他们绘制官方边境地图，并设立小标记指示边境位置。偶尔，每年只有几次，他们不得不告诉某人不要在离边境10英尺的地方建造建筑物。
So you're looking right into Canada is what you're doing right now. And you can just barely see the mountains today, just barely. But they really are, they're magnificent. And that's what we wanted. We wanted something that was peaceful and quiet.
你现在看到的正是加拿大。今天你勉强能看到山脉，只是勉强而已。但它们确实非常壮观。而这正是我们想要的。我们想要的是一种平和而宁静的东西。
72-year-old retiree Shirley Leu, and her husband Herbert, moved here to Blaine, Washington. To a piece of land right on the border, in 2003. It is not entirely peaceful and quiet. They're just up the road from the third busiest border crossing between the United States and Canada. There are helicopters and border patrol and sensors in the ground and from her backyard you can see a watch tower. People are illegally crossing all the time.
72岁的退休人员雪莉·卢和她的丈夫赫伯特于2003年搬到了华盛顿州的布莱恩。搬到了一块紧邻边境的土地上。这里并不完全平和宁静。他们就住在美加之间第三繁忙的边境口岸附近的一条路上。那里有直升机、边境巡逻队和地下的传感器，从她的后院可以看到一座瞭望塔。人们一直在非法越境。
The border itself is a ditch at the back end of her land. And the Leus accidentally started an international incident, one that may lead to the dismantling of a hundred year old treaty, and a redefinition of the president's powers. And they did it by building a wall. A wall near the edge of their property. A wall. That lots of people seem to hate. A wall--
边境本身就是她土地尽头的一条沟渠。卢氏夫妇无意中引发了一场国际事件，一场可能导致维持百年之久的条约被废除，以及总统权力被重新定义的事件。他们通过建造一面墙引发了这一切。一面靠近他们财产边缘的墙。一面墙。似乎很多人都讨厌的一面墙——
That everybody takes pictures of when they stop their cars, and shake their heads.
一面每个人停车时都会拍照并摇头叹气的墙。
[HORN HONKING]
[鸣笛声]
See what I mean? They beep horns. They moon us. They threw garbage at our wall.
明白我的意思吗？他们按喇叭。他们向我们露屁股。他们往我们的墙上扔垃圾。
The wall is four feet high, maybe 85 feet long and it's solid, concrete with rebar inside. Designed to keep Shirley's land from eroding into the ditch at the border. And, she said in the past, to hold the show dogs that she raises. Pomeranians, and poodles.
这面墙有四英尺高，大约85英尺长，是实心的，内部加固了钢筋。设计初衷是为了防止雪莉的土地因侵蚀而滑入边境的沟渠。她说过去也是为了关住她饲养的展示犬。博美犬和贵宾犬。
It's inside our property line. And when we bought the land there was nothing on our deed, or nothing on any of the old records, saying that there was a 20 foot swath there.
它在我们的地界内。当我们买下这块地时，契约上没有任何内容，也没有任何旧记录说那里有一个20英尺的地带。
No restrictions on where you could put anything.
对放东西的地方没有任何限制。
No restrictions at all, on any of our papers. And when my contractor went down to the city and county of Blaine, they didn't have any restrictions on it.
我们的文件上没有任何限制。当我的承包商去布莱恩市和县政府时，他们也没有任何限制。
You basically showed them, here's what we're going to build. You showed them plans, drawing of the--
你基本上向他们展示了我们要建造的东西。你向他们展示了平面图，画了——
We took down a plan.
我们拿出了计划。
And the drawing of the lot.
还有地块的草图。
Hm-mmm.
嗯。
And they looked at it, they said fine.
他们看了看，说没问题。
Yep. They said it was perfectly OK, go ahead and build it.
是的。他们说完全可以，继续建造吧。
So how did you hear that your wall had become the matter of an international dispute?
那么你是怎么听说你的墙已经成为国际纠纷的呢？
A guy came to the door, and knocked on the door, and handed me a pamphlet, and said I broke the treaty.
一个人敲门，递给我一本小册子，说我违反了条约。
What do you do, do you invite him in?
你当时怎么做？你邀请他进屋了吗？
No, I just stood there with my mouth wide open and looked at him. And I said, I don't understand, I broke a treaty? What treaty?
没有，我只是张大嘴巴看着他站在那里。我说，我不明白，我违反了条约？什么条约？
Surprisingly, it's relatively rare. We maybe get one or two instances per year. But most people that live along the boundary know about the boundary. They know about the restriction on building permanent obstructions within 10 feet of the boundary line.
令人惊讶的是，这种情况相对罕见。我们每年大约遇到一两起。但住在边界沿线的大多数人了解边界。他们知道在边界线10英尺内建造永久性障碍物的限制。
This is Dennis Schornack, he was the US Representative to the International Boundary Commission at the time. And if all of this sounds like a lot of fuss over a three foot encroachment to our 5,500 mile border with Canada, you have to understand that the two boundary commissioners see themselves as custodians of a 100 year old trust. To keep the border clear in a fair, evenhanded way, with no favoritism to either side.
这是丹尼斯·肖纳克，他当时是国际边界委员会的美国代表。如果所有这些听起来像是为了我们与加拿大5500英里边境上3英尺的侵占而大惊小怪，你必须明白，两位边界专员将自己视为百年信托的保管人。为了以公平、公正的方式保持边界畅通，不偏袒任何一方。
With that in mind, they send out crews every summer to chop down trees. They have bulldozed buildings. A couple years ago, Commissioner Schornack and his Canadian counterpart had to visit 40 Canadian homeowners, and give them the news that they gave the Leus. Which is why didn't cut the Leus any slack. They want to treat everybody-- Canadians and Americans-- exactly the same.
考虑到这一点，他们每年夏天都会派出工作人员砍伐树木。他们推倒过建筑物。几年前，肖纳克专员和他的加拿大同行不得不拜访40名加拿大房主，并传达他们给卢氏夫妇的那种消息。这就是为什么他们没有给卢氏夫妇任何宽限。他们想对待每一个人——无论是加拿大人还是美国人——都一视同仁。
There was one exception granted back in the 70s, and it was always referred to by staff and in documents as quote "The mistake." But there are no other exceptions that I'm aware of all along this 5,525 mile boundary.
70年代曾有一个例外，工作人员和文件中一直称其为“错误”。但我不知道在这5525英里的边界线上还有其他任何例外。
But then, on April 6, 2007, Shirley Leu and her husband did something that no American citizen had ever done in 100 years. They sued the Boundaries Commission saying that they have the right to build this wall on their own land.
但在2007年4月6日，雪莉·卢和她的丈夫做了一件100年来没有任何美国公民做过的事情。他们起诉边界委员会，声称他们有权在自己的土地上建造这面墙。
It's my property, I paid for it. I pay taxes on it. It belongs to me. It doesn't belong to the United States. It doesn't belong to Canada. It belongs to me. I paid for it.
这是我的财产，我付了钱。我为它纳税。它属于我。它不属于美国。它不属于加拿大。它属于我。我付了钱。
And, at that point, this stopped being a story about some retirees and the wall they built, and it became something much, much bigger. The Pacific Legal Foundation, a conservative watchdog group for property rights issues, and the oldest one, and one of the best known in the country, took the Leus' case for free. The Boundary commissioners were very worried about what kind of precedent this lawsuit might set.
至此，这就不再是一个关于退休人员和他们建的墙的故事，而变成了一个大得多的事情。太平洋法律基金会，一个专注于财产权问题的保守派监督组织，也是国内最古老、最著名的组织之一，免费接手了卢氏夫妇的案子。边界委员会非常担心这场诉讼会造成什么样的先例。
So they went to the State Department for advice. But officials there said, we can't actually help you, because you are not part of the United States government. You are an international body. Go hire your own lawyer. So they hooked up with a fancy private attorney who handles these kinds of big international cases. A guy named Dr. Elliot Feldman. When Canadian lumber barons, or Australian wheat gluten magnates need to hire some guy to deal with their tariffs, or their import quota problems, they call Elliot. He's that guy.
于是他们去国务院寻求建议。但那里的官员说，我们实际上无法帮助你们，因为你们不是美国政府的一部分。你们是一个国际机构。去找你们自己的律师吧。于是他们联系了一位专门处理此类大型国际案件的高级私人律师，名叫埃利奥特·费尔德曼博士。当加拿大的木材大亨或澳大利亚的小麦面筋巨头需要雇人处理他们的关税或进口配额问题时，他们会给埃利奥特打电话。他就是那个人。
And Elliot Feldman did a little research. And as best as he could tell, the commissioner did seem to have a pretty solid case.
埃利奥特·费尔德曼做了一些研究。据他所知，委员会似乎确实有一个相当扎实的案例。
He wasn't doing anything different from previous commissioners. He was probably right in doing what he was doing.
他并没有做任何与前任专员不同的事情。他做的事情很可能是正确的。
The international treaty that gave him that power had been ratified by the Senate and, according to the Constitution, any treaty that goes through that process becomes the supreme law of the United States. All very straightforward. But then, the US government did a very strange about-face. Remember, the State Department had originally suggested that the Commission hire its own lawyer. But then, commissioner Schornack found himself on the phone with a senior official from the Department of Justice named Ron Tempas, who seemed to think otherwise.
赋予他权力的国际条约已由参议院批准，根据宪法，任何经过该程序的条约都成为美国的最高法律。一切都很直接。但后来，美国政府出现了一个非常奇怪的180度大转弯。请记住，国务院最初建议委员会雇佣自己的律师。但后来，肖纳克专员发现自己正在与司法部的一名高级官员罗恩·滕帕斯通话，此人似乎有不同的想法。
He was rather brittle and rather harsh, and declared that I had to fire Dr. Feldman and turn total control of the case over to the Department of Justice. It was very threatening, quite frankly. And he said that I, personally, risked exposure under criminal laws if I continued to retain and pay Dr. Feldman. He refused to discuss the law or their approach to the case, other than to note that with respect to the Pacific Legal Fund, he said, "We know them, and they know us. I'm sure we can work something out."
他相当强硬且尖刻，并宣称我必须解雇费尔德曼博士，并将案件的全部控制权交给司法部。坦率地说，这非常具有威胁性。他还说，如果我继续留用并支付费尔德曼博士的费用，我个人将面临刑事法律的风险。他拒绝讨论法律或他们处理此案的方法，只是指出关于太平洋法律基金会，他说：“我们了解他们，他们也了解我们。我相信我们可以解决问题。”
That actually sounded alarming to the commissioner. Like Mr. Tempas might actually agree with the Leus, and the Pacific Legal Foundation.
这对专员来说确实听起来很令人震惊。好像滕帕斯先生可能真的同意卢氏夫妇和太平洋法律基金会的观点。
And about a week later I was summoned to his office, along with my deputy commissioner. And at my insistence I took along Dr. Feldman. And we were met there, at the Justice Department, by, literally, a phalanx of nine attorneys. And Mr. Tempas opened the meeting by declaring quote "There's no question that the IBC is an agency of the United States government."
大约一周后，我和我的副专员被传唤到他的办公室。在我的坚持下，我带上了费尔德曼博士。我们在司法部被一群九名律师组成的方阵接见。滕帕斯先生开会时宣称：“毫无疑问，国际边界委员会是美国政府的一个机构。”
This may sound like nothing to you and me, but to Commissioner Schornack, this was pretty much the worst thing that Tempas could have said. The IBC, the International Boundary Commission, Mr. Schornack's commission, had managed the border for 100 years independently, without interference, as an international organization.
这对你我来说可能听起来没什么，但对肖纳克专员来说，这几乎是滕帕斯能说的最糟糕的话。国际边界委员会，肖纳克的委员会，已经独立管理边界100年，不受干涉，作为一个国际组织运作。
Here they were saying, you may think it's an international organization, but we're not going to treat it as an international organization. We're going to treat it as subject to the authority of the president.
他们在这里说，你可能认为它是一个国际组织，但我们不会把它当作国际组织对待。我们将把它视为服从总统权威的对象。
Again, that's Elliot Feldman, the commissioner's lawyer. He says this was basically a power grab. The president's men at the Justice Department included some strong supporters of private property rights. They'd given speeches, they'd litigated on behalf of those rights in the past. And at this meeting they indicated a certain sympathy for the Leus' property rights claims.
同样，那是埃利奥特·费尔德曼，专员的律师。他说这基本上是一场权力争夺。司法部的总统幕僚包括一些强有力的私有财产权支持者。他们过去曾发表演讲，并代表这些权利进行诉讼。在这次会议上，他们表示对卢氏夫妇的财产权主张有一定的同情。
Ron Tempas said, according to the commissioner, don't you agree they have a Fifth Amendment right to their private property? A lawyer from the State Department said he agreed with the Leus' point of view. Don't you agree, he asked the commissioner. The commissioner did not. He and his Canadian counterpart wanted the wall to come down.
据专员称，罗恩·滕帕斯说，你不认为他们有第五修正案规定的私有财产权吗？国务院的一名律师表示同意卢氏夫妇的观点。他不问专员，你不认为这样吗？专员没有同意。他和他的加拿大同行希望拆除这面墙。
And Elliot Feldman said the whole point of the 1908 treaty which created the commission was to keep politicians from doing exactly what the Justice Department lawyers were doing right then. Interfering with what happens on the border.
埃利奥特·费尔德曼说，1908年创建委员会的条约的全部意义在于防止政客们做司法部律师当时正在做的事情。干涉边界上发生的事情。
The treaties came about because there'd been over 100 years of armed conflict along our border with Canada. Americans don't remember any of that, perhaps. But Teddy Roosevelt, at the beginning of the century, undertook a series of treaties to try to pacify all kinds of questions. And this treaty, the 1908 treaty, and the boundary waters treaty of 1909, was all part of that general movement to say, these kinds of things we don't have wars about anymore. We don't want any more violence about this. We're going to settle it. And the way to settle it is the depoliticize it, turn it over to technicians. Let them sort out the border.
条约的产生是因为我们与加拿大的边境上发生了100多年的武装冲突。美国人也许不记得这些了。但西奥多·罗斯福在世纪之交进行了一系列条约，试图平息各种问题。而这个条约，1908年的条约，以及1909年的边界水域条约，都是为了说，这些事情我们不再发生战争。我们不想再为此发生暴力。我们将解决它。解决它的方法是将其去政治化，交给技术人员。让他们整理边界。
So the treaty has words in it, like, "expert" and "surveyor" and "geographer"-- it's, if you like, I like to think of it is as one of the first technocratic treaties. Where you cede power to technocrats, and you say to them, scientifically, you figure out exactly where the border is. You mark it and maintain it. We won't interfere.
所以条约中有诸如“专家”、“测量员”和“地理学家”之类的词——如果你愿意的话，我喜欢认为它是最早的技术官僚条约之一。你将权力交给技术官僚，你对他们说，从科学上讲，你们弄清楚边界到底在哪里。你们标记它并维护它。我们不会干预。
The two countries have to do everything jointly. The two commissioners are required to act by consensus only. And they're not to be interfered with. And that way we don't have a border conflict.
两国必须共同做所有事情。两位专员被要求仅通过共识行事。他们不得受到干预。这样我们就不会有边界冲突。
That was the old way of viewing the commission. And for 100 years, it worked. The border's been peaceful. But in this meeting of the Justice Department, the Assistant Attorney General, Ron Tempas, outlined a new way of seeing it. Commissioner Schornack should see himself as serving the president, and doing what the president wants. The commissioner was, after all, appointed to this job by President Bush.
那是看待委员会的旧方式。100年来，它行之有效。边境一直很和平。但在司法部的这次会议上，助理司法部长罗恩·滕帕斯概述了一种看待它的新方式。肖纳克专员应该认为自己是在为总统服务，并做总统想做的事。毕竟，专员是由布什总统任命的。
The Justice Department lawyers told him that sometimes the interest of the commission would be subordinate to other US interests. And, of course, most important of all, he was told that the commission itself is not independent. It is not one Canadian and one American commissioner, deciding everything together. It is just another agency of the US government, taking its orders from the president.
司法部的律师告诉他，有时委员会的利益会从属于美国其他利益。当然，最重要的一点是，他被告知委员会本身并不独立。它不是一个加拿大专员和一个美国专员，共同决定一切。它只是美国政府的另一个机构，从总统那里获取命令。
Here's Dennis Schornack.
这是丹尼斯·肖纳克。
I was literally floored by that because for-- well, this is an old organization. We have archives full of memoranda and documents. Including some from the Department of Justice itself, clearly stating that we were an independent treaty organization.
我简直被震惊了，因为这毕竟是一个古老的组织。我们的档案里存满了备忘录和文件。包括一些来自司法部本身的文件，清楚地表明我们是一个独立的条约组织。
Well, if they thought that you were part of the United States, what did they think that your co-commissioner, who was Canadian-- what did they make of his existence? I mean he existed as your co-partner in running the thing.
好吧，如果他们认为你是美国的一部分，他们认为你的共同专员，也就是加拿大人，他是怎么回事？我的意思是，他作为你管理这件事的合作伙伴存在。
Well, I think you'd have to ask them that. I don't know. I can't speak for them.
嗯，我想你得去问他们。我不知道。我不能替他们说话。
Now, in this meeting did they tell you you better watch out or this could cost you your jobs? Were they as direct as that?
现在，在这次会议上，他们有没有告诉你最好小心点，否则这可能会让你丢掉工作？他们有那么直接吗？
Yeah. They were. It was rather blunt at times. They couched it in terms like, "we'll take this to a higher authority" but it was very obvious to me what was at stake.
是的。他们有。有时相当生硬。他们以“我们会将其提交给更高的权威”之类的措辞进行包装，但在我看来，什么处于危险之中显而易见。
That, to me, was very plainly a threat to his job. And in the course of the meeting, they had also made reference to-- they would see to it that we, the lawyers, would never be paid. And so we were being threatened, you'll never be paid. He was being threatened, you'll lose your job. And those were what I think they believed to be the principal levers to get what they wanted.
这对我来说，显然是对他工作的威胁。在会议过程中，他们还提到——他们会确保我们，也就是律师，永远拿不到报酬。所以我们受到了威胁，你们永远拿不到钱。他受到了威胁，你会丢掉工作。我认为这就是他们认为实现目标的各种杠杆。
Justice Department officials, including Ron Tempas, declined the chance to be interviewed for this story. A spokesman sent this email. "We believe that we have a duty not to discuss deliberations that are protected by attorney-client privilege. In addition, the district court judge has cautioned the parties regarding their comments to the press." But in court documents and transcripts from the Leus' lawsuit, the Justice Department explains their prospective.
司法部官员，包括罗恩·滕帕斯，拒绝了对此事进行采访的机会。一位发言人发来了这封电子邮件：“我们认为我们有责任不讨论受律师-客户特权保护的审议。此外，地方法院法官已告诫当事人注意他们对媒体的评论。”但在卢氏夫妇诉讼的法庭文件和记录中，司法部解释了他们的观点。
There's actually an interesting moment in the oral arguments were Assistant Attorney General Brian Kipnis tells judge Marsha Pechman how hard it was for the State Department, and various parts of the justice Department and Homeland Security to even figure out where they stood in the issues in this case. This is the first lawsuit ever against the commission by an American. And the relevant 1908 and 1925 treaties doen't say much about how the commissioners should be doing their jobs, and about what kind of entity the commission is.
在口头辩论中有一个有趣的时刻，助理司法部长布莱恩·基普尼斯告诉玛莎·佩奇曼法官，国务院、司法部和国土安全部的各个部门很难弄清楚他们在案件中的立场。这是美国人对委员会提起的首次诉讼。相关的1908年和1925年条约对于专员应该如何工作，以及委员会是什么样的实体，并没有说太多。
Assistant Attorney General Brian Kipnis says to the judge at one point, "What I was trying to convey to you is the fact that this isn't about politics. This isn't about ideology. This is about trying to get it right. This is about dealing with a lawsuit which involves issues that are, to be generous, murky."
助理司法部长布莱恩·基普尼斯有一次对法官说：“我试图向你传达的是，这与政治无关。这与意识形态无关。这是关于试图把它做对。这是关于处理一个涉及的问题，委婉地说，是模糊的诉讼。”
Judge Pechman of the Ninth Circuit is skeptical. "Mr. Kipnis," she says, "You say this isn't about politics, but there's a lot in this case the kind of looks like politics. It smells like politics. It talks like politics. What about this case isn't about politics? It certainly isn't about a Pomeranian dog run."
第九巡回法院的佩奇曼法官持怀疑态度。“基普尼斯先生，”她说，“你说这与政治无关，但这个案子里有很多看起来像政治的东西。它闻起来像政治。它谈起来像政治。这个案子里有什么不是关于政治的？它肯定不是关于博美犬的问题。”
And then Brian Kipnis says something that gets to the heart of the government's case. He says, "If there's one thing that presents great problems for us, it would be where somebody who is a US commissioner, who represents the US in international relations, takes positions in lawsuits that are not consistent with the Department of Justice. To have a US commissioner that is not under our control, taking positions we do not agree with. That is the government's view."
然后布莱恩·基普尼斯说了一些触及政府案子核心的话。他说：“如果有什么事给我们带来很大麻烦的话，那就是作为一名美国专员，代表美国参与国际关系的人，在诉讼中采取不符合司法部立场的立场。让一位不受我们控制的美国专员，采取我们不同意的立场。这就是政府的观点。”
Then Dennis Schornack's lawyer says, that's actually the point of this treaty. To cut the president and his men out of the equation.
然后丹尼斯·肖纳克的律师说，这实际上是该条约的重点。把总统和他的幕僚排除在方程式之外。
And this case is the very case that the treaties were written to prevent. That is, here's a president saying to a commissioner, I don't want you to do something you think you're supposed to do on the border. And the commissioner is saying, Mr. President, I have to do it. I'm sworn to the treaty. This is my obligation. And the president says, if you don't do what I'm telling you to do at the border, I'll fire you.
而这个案子正是条约旨在防止的案子。也就是说，这是总统对专员说，我不希望你做你认为你应该在边界做的事。而专员说，总统先生，我必须做。我宣誓效忠条约。这是我的义务。总统说，如果你不按我说的做，我就解雇你。
And the treaties were designed to say, he can't do that because there's to be no political interference.
条约旨在说明，他不能那样做，因为不应该有政治干预。
Feldman says this action on the 1908 treaty is typical of the way this particular administration deals with treaties. "We are routinely lawless," he says. There's big stuff that's been in the news, like the president unilaterally declaring that treaties, like the Geneva Convention, don't apply to certain kinds of prisoners. A reinterpretation that presidents haven't done before this way.
费尔德曼说，这种对1908年条约的行动是本届政府处理条约方式的典型。他说：“我们习惯性地无法无天。”新闻中有很多大事，比如总统单方面宣布条约，如《日内瓦公约》，不适用于某些类型的囚犯。这是一种此前总统从未以这种方式做过的重新解读。
But there's also small stuff that most of us haven't heard of. During one of our interviews, something popped up on Feldman's computer screen about a World Trade Organization case he's been following.
但也有一些我们大多数人没听说过的小事。在我们的采访中，费尔德曼的电脑屏幕上弹出了一些关于他一直在关注的世界贸易组织案的内容。
And the news story that popped up on my screen was that the United States has refused to comply with the WTO ruling. And the United States does this routinely. It routinely refuses to comply with WTO rulings, and complains that the WTO isn't being fair to the United States. The United States is a very sore loser. And when it loses, it simply doesn't do what it's supposed to do.
屏幕上弹出的新闻故事是，美国拒绝遵守世贸组织的裁决。美国经常这样做。它经常拒绝遵守世贸组织的裁决，并抱怨世贸组织对美国不公平。美国是一个非常输不起的失败者。当它输了时，它干脆不做它应该做的事。
And how can we do that? I am not sure I understand. If it's a treaty that we've signed, isn't it exactly the same as US law? Aren't all the people deciding not to do it, aren't they basically breaking the law?
我们怎么能那样做？我不确定我是否理解。如果这是我们签署的条约，它难道不完全等同于美国法律吗？那些决定不这样做的人，他们难道不是在从根本上触犯法律吗？
Yeah. But there are no enforcement mechanisms. The UN can't enforce anything, neither can the WTO.
是的。但没有执行机制。联合国无法执行任何事情，世贸组织也无法。
Boston Globe reporter Charlie Savage has followed the way the Bush administration has dealt with international treaties.
《波士顿环球报》记者查理·萨维奇一直关注布什政府处理国际条约的方式。
The administration has taken a very aggressive view that the president is not bound by treaties that have been ratified by Congress, by the Senate, across a range of issues. Or that the president, alternatively, has the power to reinterpret for himself what those treaties mean.
政府采取了一种非常激进的观点，即总统不受国会、参议院批准的条约的约束，在一系列问题上都是如此。或者总统可以选择重新解释这些条约意味着什么。
He says the change really started on December 13, 2001, when President Bush, on his own, pulled the US out of the the anti-ballistic missile treaty. Before this it hadn't been clear if a president could do that.
他说这种变化实际上始于2001年12月13日，当时布什总统单方面退出了反弹道导弹条约。在此之前，并不清楚总统是否可以这样做。
This is just a huge defense treaty. He doesn't go to Congress, he doesn't go to the Senate to see if they want to de-ratify it. He just does it on his own. And that locks down, now, into precedent, the idea that a president, in fact, has that authority. Because Congress went home. They didn't challenge him on it. There was people at the time, saying, well, wait a minute. Is that really how it's supposed to work? What if some future president goes crazy and wants to pull us out of the United Nations? Or pull us out of NATO?
这只是一个巨大的防御条约。他没有去国会，没有去参议院看他们是否想要撤销批准。他只是自己做了。这现在锁定了先例，即总统实际上拥有这种权力。因为国会回家了。他们没有对此挑战他。当时有人说，等一下。这真的是它应该运作的方式吗？如果未来的总统发疯想要让我们退出联合国怎么办？或者让我们退出北约？
Because of the Bush precedent now, a President Obama or President Clinton could simply declare, we're out of NAFTA, without going to Congress. That would be an example where conservatives would probably not be very happy about the fact that this policy decision had been made without any even consultation of Congress.
由于现在的布什先例，奥巴马总统或克林顿总统可以简单地宣布我们退出北美自由贸易协定，而无需经过国会。这将是一个保守派可能对这一政策决定在没有咨询国会的情况下做出这一事实不太满意的例子。
For two weeks after their meeting at the Justice Department, Dennis Schornack and Elliot Feldman tried to get higher level officials to step in and take their side in this dispute. But no luck. Finally, Dennis Schornack got a call from a White House official in the personnel office.
在司法部开会后的两周里，丹尼斯·肖纳克和埃利奥特·费尔德曼试图让更高级别的官员介入并站在他们这边。但没有成功。最后，丹尼斯·肖纳克接到了白宫人事办公室一位官员的电话。
And after some brief pleasantries, he proceeded to explain, once again, to me the nature of unitary government. He said, we all work for the president and we serve at his pleasure. And that I had until 3 o'clock that day to fire Dr. Feldman, and turn everything over to the Justice Department or else that pleasure would run out.
在一些简短的客套话之后，他再次开始向我解释单一政府的本质。他说，我们都为总统工作，我们听命于他。并且我必须在当天3点之前解雇费尔德曼博士，并将所有事情移交给司法部，否则那种满足感就会消失。
He went on to ask me if I was a Republican. He questioned my patriotism. And so at 3 o'clock, I called him back and said that the commission would not fire Dr. Feldman and that what he was asking me to do was, in my view, to breach my oath to the treaty, and I just wouldn't do that.
他接着问我是不是共和党人。他质疑我的爱国主义。所以在3点钟，我给他回了电话，说委员会不会解雇费尔德曼博士，在他看来，他让我做的事情是违反我对条约的誓言，我只是不会那样做。
What'd he say?
他说了什么？
"Fine." And he hung up.
“好吧。”然后他挂断了电话。
Now, do you agree that you serve at the pleasure of the president?
现在，你同意你听命于总统吗？
Well, no. Not as boundary commissioner. I believe I serve under the instrument of the treaty. And the treaty is very clear that a president can only fill vacancies. So I believe, and my lawyer advises me, I'm still commissioner. But I'm here in East Lansing, and not in Washington DC.
嗯，不。不是作为边界专员。我相信我是在条约的文书下服务的。条约非常清楚，总统只能填补空缺。所以我相信，我的律师建议我，我仍然是专员。但我是在东兰辛，而不是在华盛顿特区。
And then, if I understand right, the White House appointed somebody else to be the commissioner.
然后，如果我理解正确的话，白宫任命了别人担任专员。
They did. There was a gentleman by the name of David Bernhardt. He came in one day and took that day to, I guess, go through all my email or something, and also to send a letter to Dr. Feldman asking him to do no more work on the case. And it's my understanding, because I still talk with my staff in Washington, that he essentially hasn't been in the office since.
他们任命了。有一位名叫戴维·伯恩哈特的先生。他有一天进来了，我猜那天他花时间翻看了我所有的电子邮件之类的，还给费尔德曼博士写了一封信，要求他停止在案件上的工作。据我了解，因为我仍然和我在华盛顿的工作人员交谈，他基本上从那以后就没再进过办公室。
Schornack, and his lawyer Feldman, both continue to say that they have not been fired. Boundary commissioner is one of those positions, like International Trade commissioner and Head of the Securities and Exchange Commission, where the president can appoint you, but he cannot fire you.
肖纳克和他的律师费尔德曼都继续说他们没有被解雇。边界专员是那些职位之一，比如国际贸易专员和证券交易委员会主席，总统可以任命你，但他不能解雇你。
Which meant that what followed were several months of very odd legal wrangling, with two sets of lawyers-- the Justice Department and Elliot Feldman's team-- each claiming to represent the Boundary Commission. And two commissioners, each claiming he was the real commissioner. At one point the Leus' attorneys from the Pacific Legal Foundation filed a motion pleading with the court quote, "Before this case proceeds any further, this mess needs to be sorted out. The Leus are entitled to know which of the two defense teams represents the defendants."
这意味着随之而来的是几个月非常奇怪的法律争论，两组律师——司法部和埃利奥特·费尔德曼的团队——各自声称代表边界委员会。两位专员，各自声称他是真正的专员。有一次，卢氏夫妇来自太平洋法律基金会的律师提交了一项动议，恳求法庭，“在案件进一步进行之前，需要解决这种混乱。卢氏夫妇有权知道两个辩护团队中的哪一个代表被告。”
Canada, by the way, stayed out of this. Saying it was up to the US to figure out. Finally, in October, Judge Pechman, in the US District Court in the Ninth Circuit, ruled that the president did, in fact, have the power to fire Commissioner Schornack. Judge Pechman didn't disagree with the arguments that Schornack's lawyer made about the treaty, and how it intended to set up a Boundary Commission that would act independently, insulated from the president's power. But she said there are a whole other set of rules and precedents regarding who the president can fire that took priority in this case.
顺便说一句，加拿大没有介入。说由美国决定。最终，在10月，美国第九巡回上诉法院的佩奇曼法官裁定，总统确实有权解雇肖纳克专员。佩奇曼法官并没有不同意肖纳克的律师关于条约的论点，以及它如何旨在建立一个将独立运作、不受总统权力影响的边界委员会。但她说，关于总统可以解雇谁的一整套其他规则和先例在案件中具有优先权。
Dennis Schornack is appealing the judge's decision.
丹尼斯·肖纳克正在对法官的裁决提出上诉。
Now, you were a supporter of President Bush.
现在，你是布什总统的支持者。
I was, yes.
是的，我是。
Did you campaign for him?
你为他竞选过吗？
I did. Worked quite hard on both of his campaigns.
我竞选过。在他的两次竞选中都工作得很努力。
So what do you make of this treatment?
那么你如何看待这种待遇？
Well, you know, I'm extraordinarily disappointed. I mean, I think this is just a terrible thing. And it's one reason I wrote that I'm talking to you, because I believe the president and his men here must be stopped. I'm shocked and stunned at this seeming desire to push this very narrow property rights agenda over all of those other considerations.
嗯，你知道，我非常失望。我的意思是，我认为这只是一件可怕的事情。这也是我写信告诉你谈话的原因，因为我相信总统和他在那里的幕僚必须被阻止。我对这种似乎想要在所有其他考虑之上推进这种非常狭隘的财产权议程的欲望感到震惊和惊愕。
If Dennis Schornack loses his very last appeal, than the Leus will finally get their day in court with somebody. And it will be the Justice Department representing the Commission. If the Justice Department decides to come to a settlement, if they decide that it is OK for the Leus to keep their wall, Dennis Schornack fears that it will be impossible for the Commission to stop anybody else from building along the border.
如果丹尼斯·肖纳克输掉了他的最后一次上诉，那么卢氏夫妇最终会有人陪他们上法庭。这将是代表委员会的司法部。如果司法部决定达成和解，如果他们决定卢氏夫妇保留他们的墙是可以的，丹尼斯·肖纳克担心委员会将无法阻止其他人沿边境建造。
The commission would be eviscerated. It would no longer have any authority to do its job. The United States not only is pushing the commission around on this case, but they've fallen behind in funding for the commission as well. It's supposed to be a 50/50 deal according to the treaty. But for the last three years, 2/3 of the resources have come from Canada.
委员会将被掏空。它将不再有任何权力完成它的工作。美国不仅在这个案子上推卸委员会，而且他们在委员会的资金上也落后了。根据条约，这应该是一个50/50的协议。但在过去三年中，2/3的资源来自加拿大。
And what would the rationale for that be? It seems like this commission is doing the least controversial thing possible, which is maintaining the border with a country that we're entirely at peace at.
那基本原理是什么？看起来这个委员会正在做尽可能最不具争议的事情，即与一个我们完全和平相处的国家维持边境。
Uh-huh. It astounds me. I don't understand it.
嗯。这让我震惊。我不理解它。
Recently, he says, the Department of Homeland Security came to the commission, and asked it to clear trees and brush for 10 miles of the border in New York State, so it could test its new electronic fence. Now if the commission were actually a US government agency doing that job, they would have to pay homeowners for the foliage they were tearing down under the Takings Clause of the Constitution. The federal government can't do stuff like that without paying you back.
他说，最近，国土安全部来到委员会，要求它清理纽约州边境10英里的树木和灌木丛，以便测试其新的电子围栏。如果委员会真的是一个做那项工作的美国政府机构，他们将不得不根据宪法的征收条款，为他们拆除的树叶向房主支付费用。联邦政府不能做那种事而不补偿你。
But because the commission is an international agency, and not the US government, the Boundaries Commission doesn't pay anybody back. Which leads to this interesting thought, this whole lawsuit could lead to a very counter-intuitive and undesirable result for the government. If the administration chooses to let the Leus have their wall, if they prevail in their argument that the Boundary Commission is actually an agency of the United States government, then the short term result is going to be that it'll be a lot harder, and a lot more expensive, to keep the US, Canadian border clear and secure.
但因为委员会是一个国际机构，而不是美国政府，边界委员会不补偿任何人。这导致了一个有趣的想法，整个诉讼可能会导致政府一个非常反直觉和不可取的结果。如果政府选择让卢氏夫妇保留他们的墙，如果他们在关于边界委员会实际上是美国政府机构的论点中获胜，那么短期结果将是，保持美国、加拿大边境畅通和安全将变得更加困难，成本也更高。
Coming up. What could be harsher than playing hardball with volunteer firemen who died on 9/11? OK, maybe nothing. But something that's just as harsh. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来。有什么比对9/11牺牲的志愿消防员玩强硬手段更严厉的吗？好吧，也许没有。但有一些同样严厉的事情。过一会儿，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，当我们的节目继续时。
[MUSIC - "OH, CANADA"]
[音乐 - "哦，加拿大"]
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the show we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show: The Audacity of Government. Stories of the Bush administration's lawyering, unrelenting style, where they're inventing new ways to be unrelenting, even on tiny matters that most of us have never even heard of. We've arrived at Act two of our show. Act two, This American Wife. We have this story, from Jack Hitt.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在节目中我们都会选择一个主题，带给你各种各样关于该主题的故事。今天的节目：《政府的胆量》。关于布什政府律师式的、执着风格的故事，他们正在发明新的方法来执着，即使在大多数人从未听说过的微小事务上也是如此。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，这个美国妻子。我们有这个来自杰克·希特的故事。
Who doesn't love a good love story? Think about that moment when you first saw that girl, or that guy over there, and then, like the big bang, they expanded into everything. Even when these stories are about people we don't know, you feel a thrill and then a little jealousy, that it's not you. Like this one, about Raquel and Derek.
谁不喜欢一个好的爱情故事？想想你第一次看到那个女孩，或者那个男人时的那一刻，然后，就像大爆炸一样，他们扩展到了所有事物。即使这些故事是关于我们不认识的人，你也会感到一种刺激，然后一点嫉妒，为什么那不是你。就像这个，关于拉奎尔和德里克。
Raquel is from Brazil, and came to Florida to see America and learn to be a nurse. And then she met Derek one night on the way home from a party at a gas station. They talked, but it was getting late and she had to work the next day. Well, let Raquel tell it.
拉奎尔来自巴西，来到佛罗里达看美国并学习成为一名护士。然后她一天晚上在聚会回家的路上在一个加油站遇到了德里克。他们聊了聊，但天色已晚，她第二天还要工作。好吧，让拉奎尔自己说吧。
And then we exchanged telephone numbers. I went home. He said, what time are you going to be back tomorrow from work? And I said, I'll be home around 5 o'clock. And 5 o'clock, the telephones rings. And I was like, wow, how are you doing? I didn't expect you to call me exactly at 5:00. 5:03 or something. I just walked in the house. He didn't give any chance to breathe.
然后我们交换了电话号码。我回家了。他说，你明天工作什么时候回来？我说，我会大约5点钟回家。5点钟，电话响了。我就像，哇，你好吗？我没想到你会准时在5:00给我打电话。5:03还是什么的。我刚走进屋。他没给我任何喘息的机会。
A year later, Raquel and Derek got married. And for her to stay in the US as his wife, she had to become a legal resident. So here's how this is supposed to work: you apply for a green card. And then, sometime in the first two years, you have to go through a personal interview to prove the marriage is real. Soon enough, Raquel and Derek had some pretty solid proof.
一年后，拉奎尔和德里克结婚了。为了让她作为他的妻子留在美国，她必须成为合法居民。所以这应该是这样运作的：你申请绿卡。然后，在前两年里的某个时候，你必须通过一次个人面试来证明婚姻是真实的。很快，拉奎尔和德里克就有了一些相当扎实的证据。
We were actually on our, supposedly, honeymoon on New Orleans. And I went to the cafe, the Cafe Du Monde, on the corner right there. And had some beignets, with cafe latte. And then I just had some upset stomach right after that. So that clicked in my head that, hmm, something must be. And I told him and he said, oh, baby, you got to get the test or something. So when we get back, I got the test and it was positive.
我们实际上是在新奥尔良度所谓的蜜月。我去了咖啡馆，杜梦德咖啡馆，就在那里的拐角处。吃了些贝奈特饼，喝了咖啡拿铁。然后在那之后我胃部不适。所以那在我脑海中点击了一下，嗯，一定是发生什么事了。我告诉他，他说，哦，宝贝，你必须去做个测试什么的。当我们回来时，我做了测试，结果是阳性。
And we're like, oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. I can't believe it, I'm pregnant.
我们就像，哦天哪。哦天哪。我不敢相信，我怀孕了。
This personal interview they were waiting for is conducted by the immigration service, known as the United States Citizenship and Immigration Services, or USCIS. You know this interview, it's practically part of American legend. It's where some immigration officer grills a couple with intimate questions about the color of their wallpaper, or whether the husband sleeps in pajamas. Sometimes getting the interview scheduled can take a few months, sometimes dozens of months. It just depends on when USCIS gets around to it.
他们正在等待的个人面试由移民局进行，称为美国公民及移民服务局，或USCIS。你知道这个面试，它几乎是美国传说的一部分。这是移民官员用关于你的壁纸颜色，或者丈夫是否穿睡衣睡觉的私密问题来审问夫妇的地方。有时安排面试可能需要几个月，有时是几十个月。这只取决于移民局何时有时间。
And typically it's no big deal. Nothing interferes with the process going forward, with one exception. One devastating exception.
通常没什么大不了的。没有什么会干扰这个过程的进展，只有一个例外。一个毁灭性的例外。
18 months into their marriage, Raquel woke up to find Derek, who'd been complaining of insomnia in the living room.
在他们结婚18个月后，拉奎尔醒来发现德里克，他一直在客厅里抱怨失眠。
When I looked at him on the couch, I could tell that something, something, was going on. Something was wrong. Then I got closer, and, like, baby? And call him. I just could see that he's not breathing. And I jumped and I did everything I could, CPR, whatever. And then I jumped on the phone and get the phone and just started desperately saying, I need somebody here to help me, please.
当我在沙发上看到他时，我能看出有什么事，有什么事正在发生。有什么不对劲。然后我走近，就像，宝贝？叫他。我只是能看到他没有呼吸。我跳起来，尽我所能，心肺复苏，什么的。然后我跳到电话上，拿起电话，开始绝望地说，我需要有人在这里帮我，拜托。
It was tough. Ugh. The worst day in my life.
太难了。呃。我生命中最糟糕的一天。
Derek had suffered from sleep apnea, and that night he died of heart failure, leaving Raquel a widow. She moved in with her in-laws. And, after a few weeks, worked up enough energy to go tell immigration what had happened. She wanted to find out how best to finish up the application for residency, so she could get on with the business of raising their son, Ian.
德里克患有睡眠呼吸暂停，那天晚上他死于心脏衰竭，拉奎尔成了寡妇。她和公婆住在一起。几周后，她鼓起足够的精力去告诉移民局发生了什么。她想找出完成居留申请的最佳方式，这样她就可以继续抚养他们的儿子伊恩。
I've made appointment, went there. I gave Derek's death certificate. And they said, oh, your case is going to be denied. You're going to have to go back to Brazil. You going to have a letter from us, because you guys were not two years married.
我预约了，去了那里。我交了德里克的死亡证明。他们说，哦，你的案子会被拒绝。你将不得不回到巴西。你会收到我们的一封信，因为你们没有结婚两年。
And I said, but what? Wait a minute. I have my son here with me. He's American citizen. They say, yes ma'am, but you can go, he can stay. Just like that.
我说，但是什么？等一下。我的儿子和我在这里。他是美国公民。他们说，是的夫人，但你可以走，他可以留下。就这样。
Wow. I mean was there-- how did you react to that?
哇。我的意思是那里有——你是怎么反应的？
I just said, uh huh. That doesn't make any sense. Of course, my son's going to go wherever I go.
我只是说，嗯哼。那根本没有道理。当然，我儿子会去我去的地方。
So at this point, did you just leave the immigration office?
所以在这一点上，你只是离开了移民局吗？
I left. Exactly. I think I'm just going to go out of that door right then. And then I actually got the letter that our case was denied.
我离开了。确实。我想我当时就走出那道门了。然后我实际上收到了我们的案子被拒绝的信。
So you got that piece of paper.
所以你拿到了那张纸。
Right.
对。
And then what did you do?
然后你做了什么？
We start thinking, contact lawyers, to see what we could do. Because right there and then, I'm illegal.
我们开始考虑，联系律师，看看我们能做什么。因为就在那一刻，我是非法的。
There is no rule saying automatic denial. There is no law passed by Congress mandating automatic denial. They just made the law up.
没有规则说自动拒绝。国会没有通过任何法律强制自动拒绝。他们只是编造了法律。
That's Brent Renison, the lawyer who finally took Raquel's case. In his regular job, his paying job, he's a corporate lawyer. Mostly for Nike and some other companies. And he specializes in employee immigration issues. He's become, possibly, our nation's leading expert in cases like Raquel's, entirely by accident.
那是布伦特·雷尼森，最终接手拉奎尔案子的律师。在他的日常工作中，他付薪的工作，他是公司律师。主要是为耐克和一些其他公司。他专注于员工移民问题。他完全是偶然地成为，可能，我们国家在该案子方面的领先专家。
Six years ago, a woman found him in the yellow pages. It was an odd little case of signed, sealed, but not delivered. A woman had filed all her papers to become a resident, and very close to the two year mark, her husband died of cancer. So the government turned her down.
六年前，一位女士在黄页上找到了他。这是一个奇怪的小案子，签了字，盖了章，但没送达。一位女士提交了她成为居民的所有文件，就在接近两年的大关时，她的丈夫死于癌症。所以政府拒绝了她。
Really, I thought that would be the one strange case on this that I'd ever have. And then Carla Freeman came into my office and it happened all over again.
真的，我以为那会是我曾经拥有的关于这个问题的那个奇怪案子。然后卡拉·弗里曼走进我的办公室，同样的事情再次发生。
Carla had that same kind of situation. Bob Freeman was heading to work-- actually on his day off-- and a Pepsi truck went right across the center lane, into his lane, and collided with his car head on, killing him instantly. And that's when I met her. I went with her to her immigration interview. And we went into the officer's office there and he had her stand and swear to tell the truth.
卡拉有同样的情况。鲍勃·弗里曼正要去工作——实际上是在他的休息日——一辆百事可乐卡车直接横穿中央车道，进入了他的车道，并与他的车正面相撞，当场死亡。那就是我见到她的时候。我和她一起去了她的移民面试。我们走进官员的办公室，他让她站起来发誓说实话。
And we sat down and started talking about the application. He said, "There's somebody here to see you." And we turned and looked and in the doorway was an officer. He showed her his badge and he said, "Mrs. Freeman I'd like to first offer my condolences on your loss, but I have to ask you to come with me." And she was just terrified. And they took her away.
我们坐下来开始谈论申请。他说，“有人在这里见你。”我们转过身，在门口是一位官员。他向她出示了他的徽章，他说，“弗里曼夫人，我想首先对你的损失表示慰问，但我不得不请你跟我来。”她吓坏了。他们把她带走了。
They shackled her in chains and put her in a holding cell. Renison ran down the street to the federal court and managed to get an emergency order to get her out. He couldn't believe it had gotten this far, because it seemed so obvious that an absurd unfairness lie at the heart of these cases. And here it is: if immigration had scheduled that personal interview before Carla's husband died, Carla would have become a resident. But because there was a delay, and he died before the bureaucracy got around to it, she is subject to what they call "automatic denial." It all depends on the timing of the bureaucracy. Not the facts of the case, or the reality of the marriage.
他们给她戴上手铐，把她关进看守所。雷尼森跑下街去联邦法院，成功地获得了让她出来的紧急命令。他不敢相信它已经发展到这一步，因为看起来显而易见的荒谬不公存在于这些案件的核心。这就是它：如果移民局在卡拉的丈夫去世之前安排了那次个人面试，卡拉就会成为居民。但因为有延迟，而他在官僚机构搞定之前就去世了，她受到了他们所谓“自动拒绝”的影响。这一切都取决于官僚机构的时间。而不是案子的事实，或婚姻的现实。
And when Renison did some research into this rule, he found something that seemed impossible. This particular rule had long ago been debunked and discarded by none other than the agency's own Board of Immigration Appeals.
当雷尼森对这个规则做了一些研究时，他发现了一些看起来不可能的事情。这个特殊的规则很久以前就被该机构自己的移民上诉委员会本身揭穿和抛弃了。
Yeah, comes from a decision in 1970 which dealt with a woman who had married an American citizen who was in the Navy. And while out at sea, on duty, he died. And they denied her, saying she was stripped of the status of a spouse.
是的，来自1970年的一项决定，该决定涉及一位嫁给一名在海军服役的美国公民的妇女。在海上，在执行任务时，他去世了。他们拒绝了她，说她被剥夺了配偶的身份。
And for years after that, if your spouse died, you'd be denied residency. Because they were no longer your spouse.
在那之后的几年里，如果你的配偶去世，你会被拒绝居留。因为他们不再是你的配偶。
That was in 1970. Then, in 1985, there was a another case, Matter of Sano, that was litigated on the very same issue. And the same court said, whoa, we made a mistake. We had no jurisdiction to rule in that type of case. We're going to modify that accordingly, and we think that decision was inappropriate. I mean, the words inappropriate were used, and they're modifying the decision.
那是1970年。然后，在1985年，有另一个案子，萨诺案，在同一个问题上进行了诉讼。同一个法庭说，哇，我们犯了个错。我们在那种类型的案子中没有管辖权。我们将相应地修改它，我们认为那个决定是不合适的。我的意思是，使用了不合适这个词，他们正在修改决定。
So understand what happened here. In 1985 the immigration court held that it had no business deciding who was a spouse and who wasn't a spouse. In legal terms, no jurisdiction to decide this matter. But instead of changing the rule, the bureaucracy came up with an interpretation that let them keep doing what they were doing all along.
所以理解这里发生了什么。1985年，移民法院裁定它没有业务决定谁是配偶，谁不是配偶。在法律术语中，没有管辖权来决定此事。但官僚机构没有改变规则，而是提出了一种解释，让他们继续做他们一直做的事情。
Number one, they said they still had the power to say, you're not a spouse, based on the 1970 case.
第一，他们说他们仍然有权力说，你不是配偶，基于1970年的案子。
And, number two, you have no right to appeal.
第二，你没有上诉权。
How do they draw the no right to appeal from the second case.
他们怎么从第二个案子得出没有上诉权的？
Because there's no jurisdiction from the court.
因为法院没有管辖权。
Wow. Wow, that's amazing.
哇。哇，那太棒了。
Yeah, it is amazing.
是的，这太棒了。
So they draw these two completely at odds conclusions from these two cases?
所以他们从这两个案子得出这两个完全矛盾的结论？
Right, exactly.
对，完全正确。
So they can strip you of your status, and you can't review it.
所以他们可以剥夺你的身份，而你无法复议它。
Exactly. I'll read to you a portion of the letter that is very much the standard letter here for denial. This particular letter says, "The evidence of record indicates that your husband passed away on June 2, 2005. You are no longer the spouse of a citizen, and therefore not entitled to the status as immediate relative. There is no appeal to this decision."
正是。我会读给你看这封信的一部分，这是这里拒绝的标准信。这封特殊的信说，“记录证据表明你的丈夫在2005年6月2日去世。你不再是公民的配偶，因此无权享有作为直系亲属的身份。此决定没有上诉。”
And that's right from one of the denials. And they all have a little different flavor. Some say I'm sorry for your loss, or please accept our condolences for your loss. But, you know, you're denied and you have no appeal. It's very Kafka-esque.
那正是来自拒绝信之一。它们都有点不同的味道。有些说我为你的损失感到抱歉，或请接受我们对你损失的慰问。但是，你知道，你被拒绝了，而且没有上诉。这非常卡夫卡式。
Renison became obsessed with these cases. And as word got out about him, more and more widows and widowers showed up at his door. When I talked to him in, he had 134 clients. In 2006, he wound up in the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals with Carla Freeman, the client he saw put in shackles. And the court ruled expansively in his favor, saying, a spouse is a spouse.
雷尼森对这些案子着了迷。随着关于他的消息传出，越来越多的寡妇和鳏夫出现在他的门口。当我采访他时，他有134个客户。2006年，他以卡拉·弗里曼的案子进入了第九巡回上诉法院，这是他看到被戴上手铐的客户。法庭极力赞同他的意见，说，配偶就是配偶。
Here's precisely what they said. Quote, "Congress clearly intended an alien widow, whose citizen spouse had filed the necessary forms, to be and to remain an immediate relative, a spouse, even if the citizen spouse dies within two years of the marriage," end quote. Case closed, right? Exactly. With one exception. One devastating exception.
这就是他们精确说的。引用，“国会显然意图让一个外国寡妇，其公民配偶已经提交了必要表格，成为并保持作为一个直系亲属，一个配偶，即使公民配偶在婚后两年内去世，”结束引用。案子结了，对吧？正是。有一个例外。一个毁灭性的例外。
After she won her court case, they decided to find some other reason to deny her. And this is directly quoted from their denial. "Since your late husband is deceased, denial of your admission will not have any legally cognizable effect on him." And the word legally cognizable, that's a legal term, but I think it just means that he's not going to know what's going on with your case, and so why should we care?
在她赢了她的法院案子后，他们决定找到其他理由拒绝她。这是直接引用自他们的拒绝信。“由于你已故的丈夫已经去世，拒绝你的入境不会对他产生任何法律上可认识的影响。”而法律上可认识这个词，那是个法律术语，但我认为它只是意味着他不会知道你的案子发生了什么，所以我们为什么要关心呢？
In other words, even though she won her case, they found other grounds to throw her out, and fought this Ninth Circuit ruling in every possible way. They didn't obey it outside the Ninth Circuit. In fact, in three other circuits around the country, widows have won similar arguments and every case is being appealed by the Immigration Service.
换句话说，即使她赢了她的案子，他们找到了其他理由把她赶走，并以每一种可能的方式对抗第九巡回法院的裁决。他们在第九巡回法院之外没有遵守它。事实上，在全国其他三个巡回法院，寡妇赢得了类似的论点，每个案子都在被移民局上诉。
Inside the Ninth Circuit itself, they've dragged their feet. And finally, when forced to reply to a class action lawsuit brought by Renison, the government issued a memo two days before the deadline that said they'd abide by the Freeman ruling, but only in the Ninth Circuit, and only if the spouse met some tough conditions.
在第九巡回法院内部，他们拖拖拉拉。最终，在被迫回应由雷尼森发起的集体诉讼时，政府在截止日期前两天发布了一份备忘录，说他们会遵守弗里曼裁决，但仅限于第九巡回法院，并且仅在配偶满足一些严厉条件时。
Among them, spouses have to prove they need to stay in the United States for humanitarian reasons, because of dangerous conditions in their home countries, and they have nowhere else to go. And if some widow managed somehow to jump through all these hoops, the government can do to her what they did to Carla Freeman. To expel her from the country, they used a terrorism law. The Real ID Act of 2005 contains a clause that boosts Immigration's power. Not only can they reject any immigrant at their discretion, for any reason they want, now that don't have to tell anyone what that reason is.
其中包括，配偶必须证明他们需要为了人道主义原因留在美国，因为他们母国的危险情况，并且他们无处可去。如果一些寡妇设法跳过所有这些障碍，政府可以对她做他们对卡拉·弗里曼所做的事。为了把她驱逐出境，他们使用了恐怖主义法律。2005年的《真实身份法》包含了一个条款，提升了移民局的权力。他们不仅可以随意拒绝任何移民，因为他们想要的任何理由，现在他们不必告诉任何人那个理由是什么。
And they said those decisions that are made, as long as they're made on discretionary reasons, shall be unreviewable in any court.
他们说那些做出的决定，只要是因为酌情原因做出的，在任何法院都是不可复议的。
I'm sorry, isn't this like 1984 or something? Not to push it--
对不起，这不就像1984年什么的吗？不是为了推它——
I'd say absurd.
我会说荒谬。
But it's like, you have this special decision making power, that will be applied only with these special standards. Oh, by the way, no one can know what the standards are.
但这就像，你拥有这种特殊的决策权力，将仅应用这些特殊标准。哦，顺便说一句，没有人能知道标准是什么。
Well, you know, why I laugh about this discretionary review, so to speak, and the lack of any appeal on it, it's really nervous laughter because these are people's lives that they're destroying.
好吧，你知道，为什么我因为这种酌情复议而笑，这么说吧，以及缺乏任何上诉，那真的是紧张的笑，因为这是他们正在破坏的人的生活。
The most puzzling part of this whole story is this, what problem is the government trying to solve? What threat is worth these hardball tactics? It's not like there's a wave of widows storming our shores. These aren't fake marriages, these aren't suspected terrorists. These cases are rare. It's not like people are intentionally getting married, having kids, filing their paperwork, and then having their spouses accidentally die as a scheme to get a green card.
这个故事中最令人困惑的部分是这个，政府试图解决什么问题？什么威胁值得这些强硬战术？并不是有一波寡妇在冲击我们的海岸。这些不是假婚姻，这些不是恐怖分子嫌疑人。这些案子很少见。并不是人们故意结婚，生孩子，提交文书工作，然后让他们的配偶意外死亡作为一个获得绿卡的计划。
How much bureaucratic time would it take to just process those 134 cases, as compared to fighting this in all the circuit courts around the country?
与在全国所有巡回法院对抗这个相比，处理那134个案子需要多少官僚时间？
Well, these people paid all the filing fees, and so there's no additional burden.
好吧，这些人支付了所有申请费，所以没有额外负担。
So, I mean, they could hire a couple of clerks, basically, to finish off the paperwork here and be done with this in a couple of weeks practically.
所以，我的意思是，他们可以雇几个职员，基本上，来完成这里的文书工作并在几周内完成这个。
No, no, they don't have to hire any clerks. They do this is as a regular business. They adjudicate 30,000 applications for benefits a day.
不，不，他们不必雇任何职员。他们把这当作常规业务。他们每天处理30,000个福利申请。
Wow. And this is 134. And they're going to the mat for the right to automatically deny these 134 widows.
哇。而这是134个。而他们正在为自动拒绝这134个寡妇的权利而去战斗。
I'd say, yeah, they're going to the mat.
我会说，是的，他们正在去战斗。
Why?
为什么？
I've been on the mat for a while with them.
我和他们斗了一段时间了。
Why, do you think? Why is this such a point of contention for them?
为什么，你认为？为什么这对他们来说是一个争论点？
Well, I don't know. I honestly don't know.
好吧，我不知道。我老实说不知道。
You've reached the office of communications for US Citizenship and Immigration Services. If you're a member of the media, please press one now.
你已经联系了美国公民及移民服务局的通讯办公室。如果你是媒体的一员，请现在按1。
[TELEPHONE BEEP]
[电话哔声]
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Office of Communications.
通讯办公室。
Chris Ratigan.
克里斯·拉蒂根。
This is Chris.
我是克里斯。
Hi, Chris, this is Jack Hitt from This American Life .
嘿，克里斯，我是来自《美国生活》的杰克·希特。
Hey, Jack.
嘿，杰克。
Hi. I'm recording this for broadcast, if that's OK.
嘿。我正在为广播录音，如果那没问题的话。
Not with my permission.
没有我的许可不行。
Oh, can we get your permission?
哦，我们能得到你的许可吗？
No.
不能。
That's as much as Immigration would tell me, and it took weeks to hear that. I had called Immigration Service, and the Department of Homeland Security, and sent emails, getting either passed on, or sent to a voicemail. The main thing I wanted to ask was, why? Chris Ratigan wouldn't tell me why. It's possible the Immigration service sees this as just another part of the crackdown on immigrants that began after September 11, trying to send anybody it can home.
移民局能告诉我的就是这些，而且花了数周时间才听到。我打电话给移民局和国土安全部，并发了电子邮件，要么被推开，要么被送到语音信箱。我想问的主要事情是，为什么？克里斯·拉蒂根不告诉我为什么。移民局可能把这仅仅看作是9/11之后开始的打击非法移民行动的另一部分，试图把任何人送回家。
But, in this case, it seems like it's more about an agency that's doggedly determined to win. Just look at the constant barrage of legal talent, and massive expenditures of tax money by the Immigration service in order to toss out these widows.
但是，在这种情况下，这似乎更多是关于一个顽固地决心获胜的机构。看看移民局为了把这些寡妇赶出去而不断涌现的法律人才和巨额税款支出。
Renison now has a class action suit on behalf of the 134 spouses, and he's adding more spouses every week.
雷尼森现在代表这134个配偶有一个集体诉讼，而且他每周都在增加更多的配偶。
Brent, isn't it likely that you'll just win this case and then they'll just invoke discretionary power in every case after that? And throw everybody out anyway?
布伦特，难道你不会只是赢了这个案子，然后他们只是在每个案子之后引用酌情权？无论如何都要把每个人都赶出去？
I really hope not.
我真的希望不是。
Don't you think that's a very possibility, since it happened in the Ninth Circuit?
难道你不认为那是一个非常可能的事情吗，因为它在第九巡回法院发生了？
Yes. I try not to think about that too much, because it's really overwhelming. The power that's been given to the executive branch. And I'd like to take some of that back, but it's not my job to do that. It's Congress and it's the courts. I mean, that's how our system works. If Congress and the courts can't keep the executive branch in check, then we're really hurting in this country.
是的。我尽量不去想太多，因为它真的令人难以承受。赋予行政部门的权力。而我想夺回其中一些，但这不是我的工作。是国会和法院。我的意思是，这就是我们系统运作的方式。如果国会和法院不能控制行政部门，那么我们在这个国家真的受伤了。
What's your greatest fear in all this? What's your nightmare outcome?
你在所有这些中最害怕的是什么？你最糟糕的结果是什么？
I know what it is, but--
我知道它是什么，但是——
Are you afraid to say it because you think it might come true?
你害怕说出来是因为你认为它可能会成真吗？
Oh. Well, I don't know if I want to-- I don't know if I, well-- I think my worst fear is that I'll die before this is changed.
哦。好吧，我不知道我是否想——我不知道我是否，好吧——我想我最大的恐惧是我会在改变之前死去。
How old are you, Brent?
你多大了，布伦特？
I'm 39.
我39岁。
Do you think you might be litigating this for the rest of your life, is that what you're saying?
你认为你可能会在你的余生中诉讼这个，这就是你在说的吗？
I will if they don't change this policy.
如果他们不改变这个政策，我会的。
If Renison sounds overwhelmed, it's not because he's got 134 clients, but because he's also fighting for the old fashioned justice system. The one where a good argument before a neutral judge could prevail. Renison can sound over the top when he talks about this stuff, invoking the founding fathers, quoting America's original documents, and saying words like tyranny. But what kind of language are you supposed to use when you reread the Declaration of Independence, and realize it's just a laundry list of complaints about a unitary executive granting too much power to petty bureaucrats.
如果雷尼森听起来不知所措，那不是因为他有134个客户，而是因为他也在为老式的司法系统而战。那个在公正的法官面前可以获胜的良好论点。当雷尼森谈论这些东西时，可能会听起来过头，引用开国元勋，引用美国的原始文件，并说出暴政这样的词。但当你重读《独立宣言》，并意识到它只是一份关于单一执行者授予官僚们太多权力的抱怨清单时，你应该使用什么样的语言？
What are you supposed to say when you read a sentence like this one? "He has erected a multitude of new offices, and sent hither swarms of officers to harass our people." That old-timey language suddenly doesn't sound so old anymore.
当你读到这样一个句子时，你应该说什么？“他建立了一大批新办公室，派来了大批官员来骚扰我们的人民。”那种古老的语言突然听起来不再那么老了。
Jack Hitt lives in New Haven.
杰克·希特住在纽黑文。
[MUSIC - "GOODBYE" BY THE POSTMARKS]
[音乐 - 邮戳乐团的“再见”]
Act three, 44. A big part of the unrelenting style of this president is connected to a particular view of the Presidency, that there are inherent executive powers embedded in the Constitution, between the lines, that the Congress has no right to oversee or regulate anything the president or the executive branch does.
第三幕，44。这位总统执着风格的一个重要部分与对总统职位的特殊看法有关，即宪法中嵌入了内在的行政权力，在字里行间，国会没有权利监督或监管总统或行政部门所做的任何事情。
So, for example, you may have heard President Bush issuing hundreds and hundreds of signing statements. This is when Congress sends him a law to sign that has things in it that he doesn't think that they should be able to force him to do. Rather than go back to Congress and fight for a different bill, he simply signs the bill, and then issues a signing statement listing all the parts of the bill that he intends to ignore.
所以，例如，你可能听过布什总统发布了数百个签署声明。这是当国会送给他一项法案让他签署时，其中包含了他认为他们不应该能够强迫他做的事情。他没有回到国会去争夺另一项法案，而是干脆签署了法案，然后发布了一份签署声明，列出了他打算忽略的法案的所有部分。
Earlier in the show we heard from a reporter, Charlie Savage, who won the Pulitzer Prize for reporting on these issues for the Boston Globe . He's also written a history of all the ways that the president has claimed powers that other presidents haven't claimed. A book called Takeover , it's just about come out in paperback. The quotes from George Will and the other conservatives that I read to you from the beginning of the show actually come from his book.
节目早些时候我们听了一位记者查理·萨维奇的话，他因为报道这些问题为《波士顿环球报》赢得了普利策奖。他还写了一部关于总统声称其他总统未曾声称权力的所有方式的历史。一本叫《接管》的书，它刚刚出了平装本。我从节目开头读给你们听的乔治·威尔和其他保守派的引语实际上来自他的书。
We were wondering what is going to happen next January, to this presidential style. This unrelenting style. When the 44th president is sworn in.
我们很好奇明年一月会发生什么，对于这种总统风格。这种执着的风格。当第44任总统宣誓就职时。
And Charlie Savage has interviewed the current candidates about where they stand on these questions of presidential power that we've been talking about.
查理·萨维奇采访了现任候选人，关于他们对我们一直在讨论的总统权力的这些问题的立场。
McCain, Clinton and Obama all had reservations about some of the things that the Bush administration has done. Some of the legal claims they've made. McCain, Clinton and Obama all seem to suggest that they would take a more restrained view of executive power when it came to the question of whether a president had to obey treaties that might restrict what he or she could do as commander-in-chief, and laws involving surveillance and interrogation.
麦凯恩、克林顿和奥巴马都对布什政府所做的一些事情有保留意见。他们提出的一些法律主张。麦凯恩、克林顿和奥巴马似乎都建议，在总统是否必须遵守可能限制他或她作为三军统帅所能做的事情的条约，以及涉及监视和审讯的法律问题上，他们会采取更克制的总统权力观。
In marked contrast, I should say to, for example, the now defunct candidate Mitt Romney who embraced everything the Bush administration had done. And had he become the republican nominee, I think we would have seen a much starker contrast between whoever the eventual Democrat is and the Republican. McCain, more restrained.
对比明显，我应该说，例如，现在已不复存在的候选人米特·罗姆尼，他拥护布什政府所做的一切。如果他成为共和党提名人，我想我们会看到最终的民主党人和共和党人之间更鲜明的对比。麦凯恩，更克制。
On the other hand, there were some differences. Sometimes in surprising ways. For example, John McCain has said that he, if elected president, will never issue a signing statement. That he will only sign a bill or veto it. Period. And both Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton, while criticizing the Bush administration's rather aggressive use of signing statements, nevertheless say that they will keep using signing statements to reserve a right to bypass provisions of law that they say contradict the Constitution. Just less aggressively than Bush has done.
另一方面，有一些差异。有时是以令人惊讶的方式。例如，约翰·麦凯恩说，如果当选总统，他将永远不会发布签署声明。他将只签署法案或否决它。句号。而巴拉克·奥巴马和希拉里·克林顿，在批评布什政府相当激进地使用签署声明的同时，尽管如此说，他们将继续使用签署声明来保留绕过他们说违宪的法律条款的权利。只是没有布什做得那么激进。
The three candidates, where do they stand on the power to bypass laws in the way that the Bush administration has done. For example, the FISA law, which was signed to force the president to authorize any kind of wiretaps with a secret court before he did the wiretaps.
三位候选人，他们在绕开布什政府所做的那种法律的权力上处于什么立场。例如，《外国情报监视法》（FISA），该法签署目的是在监视前强制总统授权任何形式的监听。
I asked all three of them whether they thought the president had inherent power, under the Constitution, to conduct surveillance for national security purposes without judicial warrants. Even if a federal statute said a judicial warrant was necessary. And all three of them said that they did not think a president had that power. John McCain said, I don't think the president has the right to disobey any law.
我问他们三个人，他们是否认为总统根据宪法拥有内在的权力，在没有司法授权的情况下进行国家安全目的的监视。即使联邦法规说司法授权是必要的。他们三个人都说，他们不认为总统拥有那种权力。约翰·麦凯恩说，我不认为总统有权违反任何法律。
Now the problem with these questions is that there's still a lot of unanswered questions embedded in an answer like, I don't think the president has the right to disobey any law. The Bush administration might say that superficially too, but what they contend is that the statute that restricts the president's actions is not a law at all, because it's unconstitutional insofar as it restricts the president's constitutional powers. And, therefore, is just a bunch of words on a page, but it's not law.
现在这些问题的麻烦在于，嵌入在像我不认为总统有权违反任何法律这样的回答中，仍然有很多未回答的问题。布什政府可能表面上也那样说，但他们主张的是，限制总统行动的法规根本不是法律，因为它限制总统的宪法权力，因此是违宪的。因此，这只是一页上的文字堆，而不是法律。
What did the candidates say about the power to disobey or ignore treaties that the US has already signed?
候选人关于违反或忽略美国已经签署的条约的权力说了什么？
McCain and Obama and Clinton all indicated that they took a mainstream understanding that a ratified treaty was binding on the executive. And the question, of course, will be how does that carry over once they're in office? Once they're not being judged by voters, but are instead being forced to govern in difficult circumstances.
麦凯恩、奥巴马和克林顿都表示，他们采取了一种主流的理解，即批准的条约对行政部门具有约束力。当然，问题将是，一旦他们上任，这如何延续？一旦他们不再受到选民的评判，而是被迫在困难的情况下进行统治。
One of the things that's interesting about this as well is that Senator McCain's campaign legal advisers now are headed up by Ted Olson, who was a key player in the Bush administration's legal team. He was the Solicitor General. Ted Olson has been part of a movement that has adopted a much broader view of a president's power. And so it's one thing for a president to say, as a general matter, I think these things are binding.
这也是有趣的一点，麦凯恩参议员的竞选法律顾问现在由泰德·奥尔森领导，他是布什政府法律团队的关键人物。他曾经是总检察长。泰德·奥尔森一直是一个运动的一部分，该运动采取了更广泛的总统权力观。所以总统总体上说，我认为这些事情是有约束力的是一回事。
But a lot of the lifting here happens several layers lower in the Justice Department's Office of Legal Counsel, in the White House Counsel's office, in day-to-day matters and legal memos that are complicated, and that may never come to the president's attention. And so who the president hires, I think, will also have enormous implications for whether these trends continue, or are stabilized, or even are rolled back.
但这里的很多提升发生在司法部法律顾问办公室、白宫法律顾问办公室的几个层面下，在复杂的日常事务和法律备忘录中，可能永远不会引起总统的注意。所以我认为总统雇佣谁，也将对这些趋势是继续、稳定，甚至倒退产生巨大的影响。
Are there other questions that you asked the candidates?
还有其他你问候选人的问题吗？
One thing that was interesting is I asked them whether they believed that the Constitution allows a president to imprison a US citizen without trial or charges. And what's interesting about that question is that the Supreme Court, in the case of Yaser Hamdi, and the Fourth Circuit Court of Appeals in the case of Jose Padilla, have said yes, you can be held perpetually.
有一点有趣的是我问他们是否相信宪法允许总统在没有审判或指控的情况下监禁美国公民。关于那个问题的有趣之处在于，最高法院，在亚瑟·哈姆迪案中，第四巡回上诉法院在何塞·帕迪利亚案中，都说了是的，你可以被永久关押。
And so when I asked the candidates whether they thought that the Constitution allowed that kind of perpetual, executive detention, McCain pointed to that precedent. And Obama and Clinton said, no, they didn't think the Constitution allowed that. Which is interesting because now we have courts that have said, yes, it does allow that.
所以当我问候选人他们是否认为宪法允许那种永久性的、行政拘留时，麦凯恩指出了那个先例。而奥巴马和克林顿说，不，他们不认为宪法允许那种情况。这很有趣，因为现在我们有法院说，是的，它允许那样。
There have been 20 presidential debates on the Democratic side. And fewer on the Republican side, but still, a lot. It's been a year of campaigning. Do you believe you've seen much discussion of these issues at all?
民主党方面有20场总统辩论。共和党方面较少，但仍然，很多。这是一年来的竞选活动。你相信你看到关于这些问题的讨论了吗？
There's been virtually no discussion of these constitutional issues. It's something that everyone should be paying attention to. And the changes over the last seven or eight years have been so dramatic that what the next president does with the legacy they will inherit from the Bush administration will be enormously important. If the next president keeps exercising these powers, they will become further embedded in our system, and that will just be how our democracy works going forward.
几乎没有关于这些宪法问题的讨论。这是每个人都应该关注的事情。过去七八年的变化如此剧烈，以至于下一任总统用他们将从布什政府那里继承的遗产做什么将是非常重要的。如果下一任总统继续行使这些权力，它们将进一步嵌入我们的系统中，而这将只是我们民主制度继续运作的方式。
Is it your sense that one of the reasons why this is not become a more active issue in the presidential debate is because most people simply don't understand the kinds of powers the president has been claiming for himself?
你是否有这样一种感觉，即这不是在总统辩论中成为更积极的问题的原因之一，是因为大多数人根本不理解总统声称拥有的那些权力？
I think that's right. I think that most people who don't pay attention to this stuff on a day-to-day basis, it's a little bit abstract.
我认为那是对的。我认为大多数不关注这些东西的人，在日常生活中，这有点抽象。
In a way, it's a very abstract. But  in a way, I have to say, it's the most basic thing in the world. It's does the president think he's above the law?
从某种意义上说，它非常抽象。但从某种意义上说，我必须说，它是世界上最基本的事情。这是总统认为他凌驾于法律之上吗？
It is. It is and it isn't, because, of course, the Bush administration's legal theories is all about what is the law? They say, of course, the president's not above the law. But in their view, the law is not a statute that Congress has passed and that a president had signed. But the law is this unwritten, sweeping, inherent, undefined, constitutional powers of the president as commander-in-chief to do whatever he or she thinks is necessary in any given moment to protect national security at his or her own discretion. That's the "law" quote, unquote.
它是。它是而且它不是，因为，当然，布什政府的法律理论都是关于什么是法律？他们说，当然，总统不凌驾于法律之上。但在他们看来，法律不是国会通过且总统签署的法规。但法律是总统作为三军统帅不可写的、全面的、内在的、未定义的、宪法权力，可以在任何特定时刻做他或她认为必要的事情，以由他或她自己的酌情权保护国家安全。那是引用，引号中的法律。
The semantics here quickly become easily clouded. It's very easy for a legal team to write a scholarly seeming brief that says the law is not what the law appears to be, the law is whatever the president wants to do at any given moment. And here's a bunch of cites, and here's a bunch of pages, and this memo is never going to see the light of day, but now you are cleared, sir, to proceed and do whatever it is you want. And no one will ever be prosecuted for it because we've decided it's legal.
这里的语义很快变得容易被掩盖。法律团队写一份看起来很学术的摘要，说法律不是法律看起来的样子，法律是总统在任何特定时刻想做的任何事情，是非常容易的。这里有一堆引用，这里有一堆页面，而这个备忘录永远不会见天日，但现在你被清除了，先生，去继续做你想要的任何事情。而且没有人会因此被起诉，因为我们已经决定它是合法的。
That's certainly what this administration did over and over and over again. And there's very little to prevent future administrations of either party from doing that going forward. In fact, it's easier now than it was before because of all the precedents that have been established during the past seven or eight years.
这当然是本届政府一次又一次做的事情。而且几乎没有什么能阻止两党未来的政府在未来那样做。事实上，它现在比以前更容易，因为过去七八年里建立的所有先例。
Charlie Savage, author of the book Takeover .
查理·萨维奇，《接管》一书的作者。
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumber, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Emily Youssef Music help from Jessica Hopper
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢伯、约翰·杰特、莎拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马修韦茨运行我们的网站。制作帮助来自塞思·林德和艾米莉·优素福，音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. He looks out over the pledge room, at the money come in and rubs his hands together like Golem, saying,
WBEZ管理监督我们的项目，由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他俯瞰认捐室，看着钱进来，像咕噜一样揉着手，说着，
It's my property, I paid for it. It belongs to me.
这是我的财产，我付了钱。它属于我。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带着更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。